[Applaudissements]
jordi soler dont l'on verra les premiers
pas au théâtre dans la partie de tnt
thème peignons vous allez chez rim va y
avoir une nouvelle rubrique tpp news et
on verra donc jean michel maire avec ses
premiers pas au théâtre
c'était sa première c'était vendredi je
voulais dire qu'il y ait une exclu
dessus bon il vaut toujours consacré par
les premiers pas de jambes est chargé
vous êtes fou quoi c est non franchement
c'est énorme et vous basculez mois au
théâtre qu'à la télé bien sûr c'est vous
qui me stressait jouer toujours dit
gratitude et donc tu dois faire quoi
j'ai quoi on doit faire quoi
hays est devenu sourd attention il est
une solution doit faire maintenant c'est
à moi de m'améliorer vient d'arabie
savoir en détiennent femme vous ne le
prenez surtout pas pour la flagornerie
c'est promis j'aimerais bien être votre
épouse parce que j'aurais à mr être un
jour à la source de la création j'aurais
aimé que la femme créateurs comme ça ou
de dali voilà est à nos côtés et voir
tout le temps les fulgurances où vous
avez vu ce qu'on appelle le mozart du
paf et voir comment commence à se
rebeller le ingénieurs travaillent
[Applaudissements]
pour l'attaquant a mon avis oui
non mais vous vous foutez de ma gueule a
duré combien de temps cette affaire un
peu un petit peu voilà très bien merci